eh bien on a beaucoup parlé de choses
sérieuses vous êtes prêt à parler de
choses moins sérieuses up pourquoi pas
mais c'est leur embauche par le jingle
on accouche enfin pendant les seigneurs
c'est un gâchis
il s'est engagé à pas bougé par le
jingle pendant toute la soirée à
condition que je fasse le gage qu'il a
marqué sur ce papier mais chaque fois qu
il le montre à quelqu'un tout le monde
est mort de rire
le montrent les agents tu vois c'est la
nouvelle façon de faire de la politique
en tous les cas je vous trouve qu'ils me
disent rien cacher aux français qu'ils
appliquent tout de suite la théorie
monsieur le ministre quel est votre
première pensée lorsque vous trouvez une
femme séduisante mais j'admire c'est
tout c'est la première qu'elle est
qu'elle est le lieu idéal pour une
estrade un lit ah ouais vous n'êtes pas
t'as jamais attrapé dans la safrane les
livres d'art
à la question laquelle lieu idéal après
bon mais non quel est le vieux justement
vous seriez incapable c'est un jeu de
l'esprit bien entendu vous seriez
incapable de faire l'amour safran l'aca
est ce que vous avez besoin de faire
l'amour pour aimer ou des mets pour
faire l'amour de faire l'amour pour m
haies mais à vous avez besoin de faire
l'amour pourrait mais oui alors ça
touche à 128,6 jeu la commission attend
c'est des questions compliquées
gouvernement ils n'ont pas une question
de ce moment là tous les jours un cd
mini ces trucs qu'on n'aborde pas je ne
donne pas beaucoup ici parce que vous
faites des déjeuners avec une banda
comme ils s'appellent votre club là mais
marron ouais c'est le club
ils ont un club c'est vrai mais oui
c'est un club très donc il faut chercher
l'oiseau les dernières fois ce sont des
nez rouges non il ya martine aubry dans
le club
est ce que vous préférez j'en ai mis une
femme qui baisse vient avec un fidèle ou
une femme qui bosse mâles mais qui est
fidèle
julien gillet était tranquille il est
évident c'est génial je crois que je
vais dire qu'ils mettent bien et qui est
un fidèle
ah ouais vous préférez parce qu'à des
gens qui dans ce cas faire
ouais oui autant prendre du plaisir
ouais c'est là qu'ils disent bon celle
qu'ils baisent malek est fidèle au moins
je vais lui apprendre à bien baisés donc
le mec qui se croient pygmalion et saas
et vaniteux l'arrogance française tous à
de l'arrogance d'accord je prends dote
d'une part femme sorte de joker d'autre
part je demande à mon fils à la veille
de noël il se pique les canaux regardez
le regard de la poupée passé on dirait
pick-up voilà les us david bowie un lego
laurent blanc lé verront en anglais on
arrête irin jetables c'est pour notre
bien
alors est ce que vous préférez dans un
couple tout vous dire où rien savoir
mais bon j'ai passé une autre question
abandonne alors ça c'est une question
qui m'est henry par un téléspectateur
laquelle à vous allez voir croyez vous
écoutez bien julien ça peut vous tomber
dessus vous voyez vous que les femmes et
prix préfère pourriez vous que les
femmes préfèrent être prise sans qu'on
les comprenne plutôt que comprises sans
qu'on les prennent il s'appelle john
barch bravo
croyez vous que les femmes préfèrent
être prise sans trouver comprennent plus
tôt compris évidemment être comprise bon
sens qu'on les prennent notamment
quand j'ai un email à des nounous un
email de nounous draguignan qui dit
thierry j'ai vu l'interview jardin
secret à l'émission célébrités sur tf1
et je me demande s'ils touchent des
droit non